i also want to add this okay this is
that
you know people go well and this is why
that seinfeld thing that he said was you
know i didn't agree with it and you're
right i don't agree i don't agree with
it i couldn't [ __ ] do it
because number one um sorry jerry but as
a stand-up
you're okay
oh my god all right he invited you to
his charity gown no judd apatow did ooh
what did he call you his wife called me
jimmy
so jerry seinfeld's wife called me jimmy
and she goes what's his name i got my
name's bobby she goes and then like she
came back by the table
how's everything jimmy
and i and then i was with like i'm
sitting next to jeddah but i'm going
pretty good
you know what i mean and oh leslie man
no that's leslie manning's judge wife
i'm talking about seinfeld
yeah
no i mean he seinfeld was one of the
best sitcoms ever made yeah
yes i'm giving him that
he also created
observational comedy
right he
a kind a type of comedy that
he created which is like you know
talking about just ordinary things you
mean why is this happening and what is
up on that and you know
yeah it's basically him asking a
question and that yeah what is up with
you
this is the only minority
lunch
i didn't invite him
damn judd
right
but uh
but you have i mean
let me say something i mean
if you put
just imagine a regular audience
of just minority it is all sect of life
right you do a show
you put 2 000 people in the theater
you put earthquake
earthquake
all right
earthquake is um if you don't know
earthquake you should um
he is one of those guys that
okay think of yourself think to yourself
you didn't know who earthquake was and
you were on a show and you also didn't
know who jerry science felt like he
wasn't jerry sanford no but i want to
talk about earthquake for a second and
you didn't know where the quick and
you're like you're a booker of the show
and somebody said you should use
earthquake and you would mock at the
name
that's his name
earthquake
right so then you get him on the show
right you see this
older kind of black guy
they got this guy's name is earthquake
right
and then
earthquake opens his mouth on stage and
you're like
like earthquakes happening right you go
that's why
they call them that
that guy's funny and [ __ ] funny as [ __ ]
yeah that guy's funny as [ __ ] wrong
right
it's like when i first saw uh when i
first saw um cedric to the entertainer
steve and i
paulie goes years ago
this must have been the late 90s
and probably goes dude i'm going in the
main room you want to come with me
i go no
especially the way you said it
yes pass fast and he goes
now there's this guy
you got to see him his name is cedric
and my brother and i go
[ __ ] so we go sit next to
paulie and this is when they used to
have this show called fat tuesdays
it was just black comics
and my brother and this is way before um
what's up the kings of comedy
you didn't know who he was
i mean people did know he was in like um
you know certain certain comedy scenes
obviously but it was the mainstream at
that point now
and my brother and i sat there and
earthquake went up on stage not
earthquakes cedric the entertainer went
up on stage
and i just remember my brother and i
literally
on the floor
laughing so hard like you know one of
those where you're holding your gut
inside yeah
i i it was one of those moments where i
i went oh
i'm gonna quit
there's no way i'll never do that
you know who i felt that about leslie
yeah leslie has the same thing she has
that same thing
she she she has a thing and she's also
um
uh it
she it depends too on
what night
sometimes if people aren't into it
it could go a little awry but if leslie
jones is on
and the and the audience is primed
there's no one better yeah okay
and um yeah so um
was i even talking about or earthquake
and seinfeld so yeah that's it let's go
back
yeah let's go back okay go backwards
yeah so if you had seinfeld earthquake
uh in in front of an audience that's
bias
okay
there's no way or um science will be
able to follow
there's no possible in any word
he would eat a dick
you know and i i'm okay to say that
because
i think you would probably agree
no i don't know i me i
i just feel like i'll never know him or
you know i mean i went to that one
luncheon i you know i did i shook his
hand and that's the only interaction
i've had i don't think
that this is ever gonna get back to him
so i'm fine with that he'd be surprised
i'll let you say that
but yeah so at the same time it's like
he you know what what yeah
you know i mean i feel like
you know in his in that
driving thing that he he that comedians
he's i i feel like he said something
about minorities about like it should be
about funny not about you know i mean
minorities or whatever a race or
whatever
and i'm like no it should be about
your race as well because what you think
is funny then comedy clubs would be all
jewish dudes
if you ran it
i see you're saying you know what i mean
observational comedy yeah because it's
so subjective yeah it's all subjective
yeah yeah so no
no yeah um